my name is robin ash from the british
deaf association the bda i'm here to
explain about north east derbyshire
district council
services
what do they provide
northeast derbyshire district council
are part of
the local government
structure
north east derbyshire district council
and derbyshire county council
so each have individual services that
they provide
i'm here to explain what north east
archer district council
services are
north east derbyshire district council
have a variety of services a lot of
important services and a huge range of
services an example of this is
this is called revenue and benefit
service
there is a team that are responsible for
dealing with benefits
also to collect any revenues
these are things such as
collecting council tax
also
business rates from various businesses
in the area
they also are responsible for paying out
benefits for those people that can't
afford their rent or council tax they
help with those benefits they will also
offer advice
there are other services and this is an
example
this is leisure
there is a team who are responsible for
looking after leisure centers
and also swimming pools that are in the
area
and they also
are out in the community
and trying to actively encourage other
people to become more fit and healthy
there is another service
this is the anti-social behavior
team
the anti-social behavior team
work with the police and other
organizations
with the aim to make northeast
derbyshire a safer place to live
the work they do involves reducing crime
and antisocial behaviour
trying to reduce crowds gathering they
will offer advice to residents on how to
keep their property homes safe
and also themselves safe
another service an example is
this is planning and building control
team
they are responsible for looking after
the district's planning permission
and checking this
they will look at any applications for
planning permission for extensions or
change of use
and they will monitor this
they are also responsible for looking at
planning for
housing estates
or green areas
and they will go out and inspect
that these planning permission rules are
being followed and if not if they feel
you're breaching these they will enforce
these rules
another service they provide this is an
example
this team is the environmental health
and licensing team
this team is responsible for dealing
with any statutory duties and
responsibilities
such as taxi licensing
or
going out venues and doing food safety
inspections in restaurants pubs or local
cafes
you may report an abandoned vehicle
that's been left on the side and they
will deal with removing that
you may report a noisy neighbor for
noise
problems
or various littering problems fly
tipping they deal with that
they will also go out and check various
businesses and making sure that they're
following their license rules
and they will also go out and look for
any dog fouling
and any fly tipping or rubbish that's
been left around
will also help residents
if they have a pest infestation
insects
things like that if you report it to
them they will come and deal with that
another service they do this is an
example
this is called the street scene team
they go out and collect the rubbish and
recycling when you put your wheelie bin
up they come with their wagons and take
your rubbish away they will also go to
businesses and collect their rubbishing
recycling
they will also look after parks and
leisure areas making sure they're clean
and tidy and keep our streets clean and
sweeped
another service is
this is the elections team
they deal with
elections within the district
including national or may particularly
district elections or very small parish
elections
they will also do special elections when
they're ordered to do so
there are other services an example of
this is called social housing
the council have council houses council
flats
and that stock of buildings they own is
managed and delegated to an organization
a company called ricknord homes
that company is owned by the council but
they delegate the responsibility of
maintaining and looking after those
homes
so when you're on a waiting list if you
apply for a social housing you're going
to waiting this they are the ones that
delegate those properties they also make
sure that the houses and flats are in
good repair
within this
team there are also people there that
help people that may be at risk of being
evicted
and becoming homeless
and also they look at strategically
the plans on what the demand for houses
would be in the future
linked to the local plan
another service this is an example of
this
there is a homeless team who are
responsible for supporting those people
who are homeless
or evicted from their property and have
nowhere to go
they may be of in threat of being
homeless and that team will help support
them another service they provide is
development and regeneration team
they work with local businesses and
residents and look at improving
particular areas where the economy may
be seen to be dwindling so that it can
regenerate
they will also look at other areas that
maybe businesses are not setting up or
people are not attending and the area is
going down
and they try to encourage people and
businesses to
start up in those areas to keep the
economy going
this is a huge range of services that
north east derbyshire district council
provide
derbyshire county council
have their own services
they are responsible for main streets
highways
street lighting
library services in the various areas
and also adult social care
which covers things like social services
and support for people in the community
if you want any more information about
derbyshire county council services
please look at their website this is
their link